en la última parte del problema
descubrimos que la función de la altura
en la rueda de la fortuna o más bien de
la gente que está sobre la rueda de la
fortuna al tiempo t y que está medido en
segundos es la siguiente hdt igual a 9
menos 8 coseno de 18 t y recordemos que
la t está en segundos y nos piden
graficar esto pero en el intervalo bueno
entre 0
30 muy bien entonces vamos a hacerlo
vamos a pintar nuestros ejes vamos a ver
si me salen unos ejes derechos
ok vamos a intentarlo nuevamente
ng
a ver el segundo eje
aunque no estoy corriendo un poco pero
no pasa nada
recordemos que aquí el punto es la idea
muy bien así que aquí vamos a tener
nuestro eje del tiempo y acá h que es la
altura muy bien así que ya con esto para
saber el tiempo vamos a en realidad
quiero graficar antes una función muy
parecida que va a ser hd teta igual a 9
menos 8 coseno de zeta
entonces vas a darte cuenta que es muy
similar es muy similar el procedimiento
entonces por ejemplo aquí sobre el eje
vamos a poner en el tiempo pues por
ejemplo si aquí está aquí está el 30 es
nuestro último punto y aquí el 0
entonces a la mitad digamos estará el 15
el 20 el 25 y el 30 muy bien ahora bien
cuando te es igual a 30 muy bien cuánto
vale teta estamos pensando por supuesto
que teta es igual a 18 t muy bien
entonces cuando te vale 30 estrés por 18
3 por 8 24 son 540 verdad son 540
entonces aquí corresponde a 540
por ejemplo y bueno aquí en realidad va
a corresponder al 90 verdad 90 180
270 serían 270 luego siguen 360 y luego
siguen 450 450 y realmente es
simplemente dividir este numerito entre
18 y van a ver que les da esto de abajo
o esto de abajo multiplicarlo por 18 y
les da el de arriba muy bien entonces
voy a hacer lo voy a voy a tratar de
hacer la gráfica utilizando una tabla yo
sé que a lo mejor es muy rústico ya
mucha gente puede que no le guste este
método pero bueno es es sencillo
entonces aquí voy a poner en nuestra
tablita
en esta tabla voy a poner aquí el tiempo
aquí nuestro theta y aquí la altura
entonces teta pues va de cero
93 90 180 270 360 450 y 540 eso
corresponde corresponden e igual a 0 5
20 25 y 30 muy bien entonces estos estos
valores en realidad los tomo porque es
muy fácil de graficar con él con la
función coseno verdad entonces fíjense
muy bien cuando teta vale 0 t igual a 0
cuánto vale esto 8 por coseno de 0,90 es
1 entonces tenemos 9 menos 8 que es uno
muy bien ahora qué pasa si te traes 90
si te 390 el coseno de 90 y 0 y nos
queda simplemente
ahora qué pasa si si teta de 185 seno de
180 es menos uno por menos ocho es ocho
y nueve son diecisiete qué pasa ahora
con 270 con 270 y tenemos coseno de 270
nuevamente de cero y nos queda aquí
y ahora coseno de 360 es lo mismo que
coseno de 0 entonces aquí se repite
exactamente coseno de 360 es uno y
tenemos nueve menos ocho es uno luego se
repiten nueve y luego se repite
diecisiete y ya con esto podemos ir
graficando fíjense muy bien
vamos a poner aquí el 1 2 3 4 5
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 y 17 muy bien
entonces ponemos nuestras referencias
porque sólo hay 19 y 17
hasta el 17 aquí han del 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
digamos unas líneas auxiliares más o
menos así
unas líneas auxiliares para que nos
fijemos bien donde es que vamos a andar
graficando aquí tenemos el 9 también
ponemos nuestra línea
estoy
mucho cuidado para que se entienda muy
bien que estamos haciendo
bien aquí
muy bien creo que creo que con eso basta
y ahora vamos a graficar lo vamos a
graficar lo esto tiene forma de coseno
entonces en cero vale uno aquí anda
nuestro primer punto en dejen de hacerlo
con con un color más vivo
con verde
aquí andamos en 1 en 5 o bueno en el 90
andamos en 9
en este punto en 180 estamos en 17
y luego repetimos 9
luego repetimos 20 aquí en en 1 perdón
luego en 25 estamos acá y luego en 30
estamos hasta acá arriba muy bien
entonces nos dicen bueno aquí sabemos
que esto tiene una forma de coseno así
que vamos a graficar lo más o menos como
un coseno
ahí está
y más o menos
ahí lo tienen un coche no
y luego vuelve a subir y hasta que
llegamos a nuestro último punto muy bien
y ahí está ya la gráfica de está
entonces lo último que nos piden es
aproximar cuando 3 4 y 10 por ejemplo si
nos vamos a 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 por
ejemplo aquí pues no sé es más es más o
menos abajo del del 9 puede ser no sé
quizás 8 7 o algo así o 6 y nos piden
aproximar también alrededor del 10
entonces de hecho en 10 y sabemos cuánto
vale y es 17 metros verdad está a una
altura de 17 metros así que yo sé que al
trabajar con con funciones
trigonométricas se puede volver un poco
alborotado pero pero el problema fue muy
fácil y no hubo mayor complicación
espero espero de verdad que te haya
gustado